hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round 10 of the 2019
singled Cup it's Magnus Carlsen versus
Wesley's soul and it's really a long
theoretical struggle where it just shows
you how important it is to always study
the endgame so without further ado let's
check it out Magnus Crossan still
without a loss but also still without a
win all games have been drawn so far
let's see what happens Coulson opens
with E 4 with E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and Bishop to c4 with Bishop to c5
the Italian game is on the board and
here of course b4 is an excellent idea
the Evans gambit you should always play
it but it was not played in this game
here a magnus castled i know life isn't
fair but what are you gonna do with
Knight to f6 d3 Iago piano is on the
board and we have castles by black with
C 3 d6 and the now h3 just making some
room for King taking away the g4 Square
from blacks pieces with h6 Wesley does
the same and now rook to e1 with a 6
this is all standard Jaco piano stuff
with a for preventing b5 and here with a
five-night BD 2 by Magnus and here
Bishop Bishop to e6 by Westar was played
West they already had this position
against unease Gary in the Grantchester
they was played in Zagreb where Bishop
to e7 was played I didn't game ended in
a draw against Gary but here Wesley
prefers Bishop to e6 and here Magnus
avoids the trade with Bishop to b5 with
Knight a7 attacking Carlson's bishop and
the now V for Wesley goes eke a person
before he captures and v4 is possible
Peter Svidler played it against the
moxie marshal de Graaf in 2017 World Cup
in Tbilisi Georgia and that game ended
in a draw but here again it wisely
prefers 95 it's a much more common move
in this position D captures on c5 and
now Knight back to a 7 with b3 by
Carlsen preparing Bishop to a 3 also
this night is not
supported if if Magnus wants to bring it
over to see for which he does as you all
have seen from the thumbnail we've
looked at I ate and now seek after Sundy
six with Queen captures and v6 and
worship the a3 attacking the Queen and
this position has been reached before
both both times it was reached it was by
Maxime Bashar Allah graph for example
once he reached it against Greece shock
where Quinta a6 was played by Grisha
also in the 2017 World Cup in Belize
Georgia that game ended in a draw second
time was also against between maxi
paragraph but I don't know who his
opponent was maybe even Wesley so where
c5 was played yeah I was yeah I was the
max emotional girl where versus Wesley
so but it was a blitz game in the same
Clarissa blitz tournament that was
played ten days ago and in that game we
had Quinta e 2 so this was played by
Maxime against Wesley but Magnus goes
for Knight to c4 it's a new move and it
offers a well to go into the end game
right away so what are you gonna do your
queen is under attack and you have to
play something you could move the Queen
or it's a Queen d7 just get out of the
way or Queen the c7 but Wesley prefers
the Queen captures Queen with rook
captures only one and now Bishop
captures on c4 so this is a strange
thing to allow be captures on c4 and you
can see that magnets voluntarily ruined
his pawn structure here but what it does
is it keeps an eye on the be 5 square so
for the rest of the game Wesley Wesley
will have a week beep on you will never
be able to put b5 and also for the
moment cause and has control of the D
file so it does have a plus side to
ruining your pawn structure but
obviously Magnus prepared something as
he did played this line with b6 by
Wesley and now Knight h4
a very nice move that the you know is
it's a multi-purpose move you can't go
rogue d6 right away it doesn't really do
anything
yes it's a very nice rock lift you're
you're hoping for rock 81 but night
the c8 is coming attacks the rook
defends the b6 pawn and now you have to
go back if you try something like rook
to c6 then then black will go Knight d7
guard d5 pawn rook a7 to keep an eye on
the seventh rank and then Knight east
seven and your rook will you know get
get in trouble for for overstaying his
welcome
so imagine is prepared Knights the h4
here and now rook a to d8 if you try g6
right away to prevent the night let's
say from reaching f5 then rook d6 is
very strong because now it comes with a
double attack against the knight and the
pawn on d6 so first we have after
knighted for rook 88 by Wesley and now
crossing goes f3 we have g6 now it's not
a problem since now Wesley's route also
guards the d6 square and now g3 and now
you can see that this Knight is now
coming to g22 III and d5 and from there
it will also help out with an attack
against the weak b6 pawn whereas the
rook will go to be won to constantly
keep an eye on the b6 pawn with nice to
h5 by Wesley and now King to f2 the
first defending the pawn with Knight
back this knife the c6 and now Bishop
the c1 the bishop is no longer useful
and is diagonals across and transfers it
to this diagonal here with King to g7
also the h6 pawn was under attack and
now bush of the e3 we have rook after
sandy one rook captures and rook to d8
Wesley hopes to trade the other pair of
rooks as well but Magnus is not
interested he needs this rook to
constantly put pressure on this pawn
here and rook to b8 you have to play it
even though it's it's a tough move to
play now you you can never move the
knight if you move the knight your rook
is not protected Bishop captures and c5
would we would be possible so here
what's this position is very passive his
rook has to keep an eye on the beasts
exponent and his knight has to stay
there to keep an eye on the rook
otherwise you're getting Bishop captures
on c5 and now the plan we've discussed
Magnus needs to get this Knight to d5 so
how do you do it first you need to move
the King you need to move the bush
make room for the night on e3 and then
you can play 9g to e3 to d5 and this is
what Carson starts Knight G - we have
Knight to f6 Wesley now get tries to get
the other night into the game King eetu
making room for the bishop so you can
make room for the night we have 98 and
then out push up the f2 freeing the e3
square for Magnus's night with Knights
the d6 and now tonight the e3 and here
Wesley plays in Knight to e7 the to me
tonight d5 with Knight captures on d5
but it's not a problem this is exactly
what Magnus wanted we have Knight to d5
now comes Knight captures on d5 seek a
press on d5 or you can just you can't
allow the Knights to remain there and
now comes Luke to b7 again you have to
play it because again there's the threat
of Bishop captures on c5 your rook unbe
a design go unprotected so Luke to b7
again a very passive position for Wesley
as the rook has to keep an eye on the
pond and the knight has to keep an eye
on the rook all the time so there aren't
really any active moves here
Carlson plays King to d3 and also the
knight has to remain there not only to
defend rook even if you could defend the
rook some other way you don't want to
allow King c4 to b5 to c6 that's just
game over so Wesley has to try an active
plan with f5 and now Carlson plays an
excellent move c4 c4 with the idea of
transferring this bishop to this
diagonal now Bishop the e1 with the
threat of Bishop captures an 85 and
black has no no good ways of meeting
this threat now what's the play pawn
captures we have pawn captures and now
you can't just wait for example if g5
you just get Bishop to e1 and there's no
defense Bishop captures an a4 and a5 is
coming then this point falls and so on
and so on
so after F captures an e for Wesley
decided to abandon the b6 pawn he played
rook to f7 he went after the bishop on
f2 what caused and said okay this is
exactly what I wanted
rook captures and b6 we have rook
captures an f2 and our rook captures on
b6 rook f3 check King e2 and now rook
the c3 if you capture this pawn
then rook c6 you make room for this best
point you're gonna capture here capture
here and well the central pawns are more
important than than these guys here so
Wesley goes for the c4 pawn with rook
the c3 and now rook the e6 we look after
some c4 rook captures on e5 and now
comes Luke captures an a4 material and
the board is equal but that's beside the
point we have looked east 7 by Magnus
and Magnus has two connected passed
pawns in the center of the board and
here with King to f8 the game would
continue white would play rock e6 ago
after these pawns you can go look c6
behind this point you can go low k-6 go
after that point but still you're gonna
play king of three and guard your porn
and start pushing your deep on this is
the idea here
however after rook to e7 check Wesley
played King to f6 but this just loses on
the spot so feel free to pause the video
and try to find why it loses on the spot
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just won on the
spot and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show here at Carlson played d6
and it was in this position that Wesley
saw resigned the game on move 43 what if
you resign well now there's no defense
c5 check is coming and then they spawn
just Queens for example you could play
rugby for you could put a look behind
the past pawn but those are two
connected passed pawns e5 check is
coming in the five and not d7 and well e
six is coming this will guard the pawn
so whatever you do and there are no
active moves here
rookie four check is nothing you're just
gonna move the king so let's say h5 e 6
is coming and then after King F 6 just
rocky 8 and now whatever you do just the
8 Queen and it's a game over so really
really amazing stuff and it's really
amazing how simple this game is how
Magnus improved and the game Maxie
marshal de Graaff played against Wesley
so in a blitz game in the Saint Louis
Litts tournament just played that night
c4 voluntarily ruined his pawn structure
but it was such a such an incredible
active position for white whereas black
had no no options it's really an
interesting game for
for some longer analysis where you can
learn a lot from the end game but also
where I use this quote by pal Benko and
I'm gonna use a bit more of his quotes
in the future videos agreeing to drawers
in the middle game equal or otherwise
deprives you of the opportunity to
practice playing end games and the
endgame is probably where you need the
most practice so if you feel you are
you've studied the end game more than
your opponent you definitely want to
play and then game even if it's an equal
end game and you just might outplay your
opponent so here really really a
remarkable remarkable game such a simple
elegant game and I really liked it so I
hope you enjoyed it as well now let's
check out the standings as this really
influences the standings as now cross
and caught up to the leaders well not
the leaders being Liron still the sole
leader with six point but then we have
Magnus neppo Anand and kurakin with five
and a half points with with five points
Caruana maxime holographic are clear
Monty are off with four and a half
onigiri and he Cara Nakamura and with
four Wesley so and eleven are none it
will be interesting in the final round
cross and faces maxime beaugeois graphic
or sand has the black pieces so his task
of overcoming Maxime is you know greater
with the black pieces
whereas ding the leader of the
tournament faces Mahmoud er of and if
ding of course wins in the last round
ding wins the tournament and I caught a
glimpse of the interview with Mahmoud er
off he said that he has never beaten
ding in a classical game he had a +10
evaluation against him and ding is just
such a strong fighter he survives
anything like you've seen in his game
against Anand we're on just had
everything but Bing was able to defend
because ding really thrives in in tough
complicated positions with lots of
tactical opportunities that's you know
that's his happy hunting ground and it's
gonna be very interesting what mama DRF
can try with the black pieces against
the in the final round
so everyone still has a chance it's
still you know all the options are open
in the
in the last round and it's gonna be very
exciting sure that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Jonathan Willis Jarvis Paul guest and
Steve communites
Kimmons for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with another video probably
from round 10
continuing the Capablanca saga and of
course checking up on your suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day